it's friday the last day before the
weekend which means this is the last
horror movie review of my horror movie
extravaganza horror movie review
extravaganza that is
thank you all for sticking around thank
you all for being interested in what i
have to say about
these horror movies now let's review the
final
chapter
[Music]
candyman so candyman came out in 1992
another movie that came out in 1992 bram
stoker's dracula
was my previous video it really stars
virginia madsen she plays helen she's
doing a thesis
on urban legends and that's what this
movie is about it's about the
investigation of urban legends
which leads her to the legend of
candyman which then brings her to where
candyman is supposedly appearing where
the legend is and that's cabrini green
that's housing in chicago a place that's
clearly been neglected by the system
it's an investigative movie it's an
investigative
psychological thriller with really
effective
horror elements and if they thread the
needle if they hit the bullseye on all
of those
aspects that would make candyman stand
out
among horror movies and they do and it
does and i guess one of the reasons that
candyman just
instantly fascinates me is there were
whisperings about candyman
when i was a kid on the school bus there
were no rumors about freddy krueger
actually killing someone no rumors about
jason voorhees
actually killing someone however someone
had a story they heard from someone they
heard from someone they heard from a guy
who gave them the blood code for super
nintendo
mortal kombat that doesn't actually
exist that so and so knew so and so who
was being babysat by somebody and that
kid
said candyman five times and the mirror
and the kid died like no one died it
never happened but the whispers were
there on the back of the school bus
on the ride to school so candyman was
already in my head
years before i even saw the movie and
there's a lot to like about candyman
first of all like i said
it's a compelling investigative film
it's not just
people getting killed and sliced up by
this candyman for the sake of gore
and horror no this movie treats horror
how some of my favorite horror treats
horror which is an interesting
plot maybe there's a mystery in which
with candyman there is you're being
carried through this plot by compelling
characters not to say people don't die
in bloody fashion in here
but it's sparingly done the sparing use
of tony todd in this movie is
really what keeps him feeling special
that in his booming voice all right
if you're gonna procrastinate on
watching candyman if you've never seen
candyman before
i will understand if you're holding out
to get that stereo system when it's on
sale with great sound and great bass
after you get it though watch candy man
because tony todd's voice
is booming in this movie it gets in your
head
it's like a sound wave that pierces
through your skull
to the center of your brain to your soul
which is clearly how she
hears it again that gives you that
feeling of is he even real
and i love that i love a movie that
keeps me on the hook with a question
even after the movie's done and they're
deconstructing it like well
huh i it the mystery lives on
after the movie's even over and i think
the plot of candyman is amazing it's
actually quite brilliant
just the logistics of candyman and why
he shows up because he gets his power
from people's belief in him people's
belief in candyman is what gives him
power
and as long as people don't say his name
five times in the mirror obviously they
believe in him
enough for him not to have to show up
but if anyone's ballsy enough to say his
name
five times in the mirror obviously the
legend is dying and he's losing power so
he needs to show up and slaughter a
couple people you know in the name of
the legend and thus the legend will live
on the stories will live on people's
belief in him
will be rejuvenated it's just better
than a guy shows up and kills you
because you said his name
five times i love the reason and this
movie came out in 1992
studios producers i'm pretty sure they
were doing rock paper scissors to
whether or not horror movies would just
go straight to dvd for the straight to
dvd rack at am pm or a gas station or
something handyman comes along and shows
hey
horror movies don't have to just be
horror schlock
they can be compelling pieces with an
interesting investigative element i mean
the movie has some horrific imagery and
some
blood and violence don't get me wrong
but most importantly it never
felt unnecessary it always added to the
saints it's such a rarity out there how
many times you watch a horror movie and
you're like well that was overly bloody
but you know
they're doing the horror movie thing you
can kind of take it or leave it
maybe if you're a gore hound you like
seeing it you know maybe it's not too
necessary in candyman
the gore always felt necessary it always
drove it forward you know the shock
of some of the gore was necessary to hit
you and if it wasn't that shocking some
of the scenes wouldn't have been as
impactful and the musical scar
we can't leave without talking about the
musical score the musical score in
candyman is amazing it hits all the
right notes and all the right tone to
perfectly illustrate the tone that is
candy man beautiful
powerful chilling a great musical score
can be a very powerful
element among the great horror movies
out there candyman
has a great one i watched a lot of
horror movies this month some i watch
every year some i hadn't watched in a
very long time
and of my revisits this was one of my
favorites i love the lore i love the
investigative element i love tony todd
virginia madsen's awesome tony todd's
captivating yet
brutal and those are always the
characters i just have the most fun with
as you saw in my bram stoker's dracula
review it's a movie that elevated horror
it
elevated its own genre transcended its
own genre
it's not just a great horror movie of
the 90s
it's a great horror movie when put up
against
any horror movie from any decade it
truly is a classic and it truly does
earn its place among the order of horror
movie classics candyman is not just a
horror movie
it is awesome tacular
now i gotta look into whether or not my
camera has a mirror in it or not
because i've said the name candyman more
than five times
which means i might just be [ __ ] but
that is a funny thing like i'm not even
a superstitious person i don't believe
in that kind of stuff
however and that's what keeps candyman
so real to me
is it's it's the only movie in my adult
life
that i still think about in that context
i know it's not possible for freddy
krueger to kill me
i know zombies aren't real so jason
voorhees is out michael myers is a
possibility
he's just a psycho and a mess however in
the end i still haven't said candyman
in the mirror five times but that's wild
that's something that so defies
logic it's just i still won't do it all
right so candyman have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you